I want to congratulate it's very rare
that I get to say that a comedian is on
the Forbes list of successful comedians
this has got to be a life changer for
you
I mean well according to the guys back
in Chicago it's not really that big of a
deal I got I got a call from them
they're like they're very negative yeah
so they're like listen it's not gonna
last so enjoy it now you know your
tongue could fall off next week thanks
George so they do they would you say
your friends are are they treating you
differently or any friends treating you
differently now that it's clear that
you're making a lot of money no it's
everybody just we just constantly rip
each other to shreds
oh that's best our friends right right
and the even the Forbes article I said I
still got three or four buddies back
home that ripped me to shreds so my
buddy calls me up he's like what do you
mean three or four who's the four man
yeah yeah he's Maggie and getting there
I do have a funny group of friends are
your friends funny my my friend George
is probably the funniest out of the
group he's actually I think funnier than
I am
so all my friends are like he should be
on the Forbes list what is he what does
he do he's a painter
he runs a painting company but if
there's one guy that makes me cry
laughing its George right yeah right you
ever think of talking him into like hey
get on a plane come out here leave the
painting behind I'll get you a leather
jacket you'll be a big hit no I think
he's happy happy where ya go I don't
think he's going anywhere
you